listen i appreciate drake's music i
think
uh take care is the closest thing he has
to a classic
uh i think that i'm still waiting for
him to wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute i don't think he has a classic
like
undeniable classic i think take care is
probably the closest the closest
thing he has yeah because it's not a
consensus classic
it's a classic to me like take care is
not a classic i
i think it might be to me okay but i
think
it's not a consensus like you know doggy
style no one would tell you doggy style
isn't a classic
can actually take care people will be
like
nah that wouldn't like there are like
like i'm talking we know the albums get
rich or die trying is in the rafters
what and by the way i have to only rap
to make a classic album
eminem doesn't have a consensus classic
he doesn't
i agree which one buddy eminem come on
man i agree
but because are we talking [ __ ]
marshall mathers lp is a consensus
hip-hop classic
i don't know not at all sir i don't know
not at all
no there was some [ __ ] on that album
i don't know i'm with kev on this one
but eminem is one of the gr
and by the way he's got three really
good albums that are close he has
great albums slim shows marshall mathers
lp and eminem show
there's arguments to be made that those
three albums are classics but they're
not
consensus classics eminem doesn't have
an album better than get rich or die
trying
period i agree eminem doesn't have an
album better than doggy style or
ill-matic
like the the consensus classics are the
ones where there's just no
can you drake i think has two
classic ish take care
it's they're on the same level i don't
know
i don't know i don't know i would take i
take care of the [ __ ] classic
i would take to me it's a classic but
it's not like and i'm a
hip-hop fan but just this is why i want
to ask this question
because i feel like right we cheat
people with the classic word
we say people don't have a classic
because they may have a song where
they're singing
no no but i feel like a lot of times we
do that because like drake said in an
album before
classic is just ten of these you know
what i'm saying he's just saying like
i'm
like y'all just want me to rap so does
something not become a
hip-hop classic because it may have a
pop record on it nah you know what i
think what drake's missing
from his uh repertoire is that i think
up until scorpion drake had a really
hard time
of letting us into who he really is
wait wait wait wait wait i mean that
like through his music and furthermore
drake has never really taken a stand on
any sort of political issues
or like danced out of his comfort zone
when it comes to the content he's
rapping about
is that not fair that's not fair
criticism am i the only one hearing this
by the way let's like let's listen to
this like come on guys
this is on a classic album drug ballad
come on this sucks dick bro did you hear
what he just said
so this is a this is on a classic album
this shitty ass eminem song is on
marshall matters
this song sucks did you hear what you
just said
what did i say you just said drake never
opened up until scorpio
i mean like about his purse like he's
talking about he's been telling us about
his life
he's talking about [ __ ] he [ __ ]
he's talking about being heartbroken
but i'm talking about talking about his
mom and his dad's relationship
i know his girlfriend name from her i
have no idea i know the girlfriend i
don't know
i don't have a state of health no idea
what drake's political leanings are i
don't know how it feels about social
issues
i don't know well maybe that's okay
that's different
i have no idea who like i don't know
where i don't know his opinion on a lot
of things
outside of he likes fat [ __ ] with
girls with fat asses that used to work
at hooters
you know what i'm saying no no drake
also is the kind of guy
i would suspect drake also subscribes to
a lot of only fans accounts for sure
listen drake opens
up about a lot of things does he not
victims how many only fans account
subscriptions do you think you got
that's not my business
i think drake's in the dm's are only
fans like yo what's up girl this is
drake no for real it is
i just wanted to support drake has three
classes give you this 14.99
what are the three i think take care
yeah if you're reading this too late
i uh you know what i can't i i know a
lot of people say that but yeah he
didn't write
nothing was the same nothing was the
same as the the two for me it's nothing
i think nothing was the same as best
album personally
me too but i think take care is the one
that's like there's not one song you can
skip on take care
i don't disagree it's nothing it's a
great album you can't skip one song one
two weeks
i think that's the only i think in the
last uh
you know recently let's say the last 10
years
2012. so let's say the last eight years
i think that the only
i'm not saying that there's not other
classics because i do think
writing is a mad lib guy classic but
these are classics that like
well kendrick has three classes now
listen i was gonna say
the only consensus non-deniable classic
album that's come out is good command
city
because to pimp a butterfly is a very
controversial album it's very polarized
that's
classic i don't disagree with you i
think kendrick dropped three classics in
a row i mean through the lens of like
nobody is going to say the good kid matt
good kid mad city is up there with good
richard
yeah to pimp a butterfly is one of the
most polarizing albums ever
i think it's a classic thanks i actually
think it's probably kendrick's best
album in my opinion i think damn
no that's his worst album in my opinion
out of the three but because
but damn is a classic in my opinion he
kind of meshed both no i agree but damn
is a classic yeah so for so for me just
out of those three i put it i go uh
you know either good can match it or to
pick a butterfly you can go the way they
came out but
but i think the only album
in the last eight years that we look at
and we're like that is a classic
nobody can say [ __ ] is that album now i
have opinions on other projects that i
think are classics
okay but i just mean like
there's just those albums that you're
like would you say
my twisted dark fantasy of course that
was 2010.
that was 2010. that to me is the best
album i've ever lived no that was 2017.
2010. i mean connie is my favorite
artist what about watch the throne
no you don't think that's a classic not
a classic i think it's a good album
there's some good [ __ ] on there
you know i eat it can't argue that i
actually think i think jesus is a
classic
i think geez has changed sonics and hip
hop i agree
i think the astral world is a classic
but guess what i'm talking about
just like you like there nobody could
say [ __ ] about good kid mad city yeah
no i agree i'm saying damn is my
favorite because
and me maybe maybe force hills drive
maybe and i don't maybe
maybe but it's not on the same level as
good kid mad city see what good kid
like is so dope because it was like not
only his first
introduction but it was just so classic
right but for me as an artist
the psyche of an artist is hard to
continue to do that
right so for him to come with something
as polarizing as the pimple butterfly
and then meshed to pimp a butterfly in
good kid mass city into a dam
yeah you know commercially as an artist
had his biggest records
yeah like that's a hard thing and i i
don't want to say that there's not other
classic albums in that eight-year span
i think my crazy life by yg is a classic
but i think
i think that i don't know if
[ __ ] i definitely think my crazy
life is i
i agree but i don't think people like if
you talk to [ __ ] in new york
they might be like nah that [ __ ] was
just all right
i mean like yo these are this hall of
fame album
nobody's gonna say [ __ ] when you put
that up there on the mantle yeah no one
will say [ __ ] if my beautiful dark
twists and fantasies on the beds
or reasonable doubts or good kids get
rich
yeah so i mean look eminem's all-time
great and i personally
don't think he's got a a consensus
classic i agree
i agree he has great albums but as far
as just a classic from top to bottom
in my opinion i don't know yeah i don't
know
but without them and them no yeah i
think m m shows my favorite m m album
eminem show is my favorite eminem album
definitely i even like uh the encore
album as well though
encore had some [ __ ] on it that was like
it had some really bad [ __ ]
like some of the worst [ __ ] i ever heard
but it had some [ __ ] that i loved he had
some dope [ __ ]
he had something like that that uh that
that he just had some [ __ ] i was in a
really toxic relationship
yeah and he had some [ __ ] i was like
yeah
this [ __ ] talking to me